Shane Stanley, Filmmaker/Author/Instructor:
I think Netflix if you make a deal with
them they acquire the project
I think people will be surprised for what
they actually acquire independent films for.
Film Courage: What kind of money are
distributors paying for movies today?
Shane: It depends. You can get a good distributor
to come in and it's all about territories,
how much term how long is the contract going
to be making deals with certain platforms or
certain distributors looks really good on
social media and at cocktail parties but
some of those deals can go 25-30 years now and
they pay a couple hundred grand maybe maybe more
but what are they owning and for how long and
what does that limit your other sales potential
I'm a big fan of trying to sell films territory
by territory there are times where you get
opportunities to sell them in a block where
somebody will come along and say we want to own
10-11 territories and here's what we're willing
to pay sometimes it's good sometimes it's not
I think you have to look at both sides of it you
have to look at the long term or how long are
they going to have it sometimes these these awful
financial offers come with 30 years on the other
side where I'm 50. I don't need to be 80 to get
the rights back so sometimes the lesser money per
territory if it's shorter term three to five years
could be more attractive every deal is different
you may get every territory spending between ten
and forty thousand dollars but there's ultimately
fifty plus territories to sell around the globe
they take time a lot of them don't pay up front
a lot of them don't pay until they have it
delivered and it's past QC so just because
you make a deal you may not see the money for six
months people forget that so that's again why when
you're an independent filmmaker I think you have
to look at the real picture it doesn't mean you're
not going to have something that just surprises
the world and you just make a huge deal that that
does happen but it doesn't happen to everybody so
to be a blue collar filmmaker and to be able to
continue to do what you do you have to to keep
that in mind I think you have to you realize that
the average deal is going to probably be five to
seven years that a territory is going to come in
are they going to pay 50 upon execution of the
deal are they going to pay 50 upon delivery that's
that's an attractive way to go where they're going
to put up 50 upon signing and then when you get to
your sales agent you're going to have a quality
QC version master that they'll be able to deliver
and all that went through so you're not doing
it territory for territory once you have that
qc that's passed that show that's past muster
everybody's going to get that when they get it
but I know two deals are the same you can have
one film where all of a sudden the uk or germany
is paying 45-50 grand and then china is going to
pay 10 or 15 and then you can have another film
where china's paying 35 40 and then the uk is
paying 10 or 15. it's it's never consistent
again it goes back to genre big with genre also
cast does it fit what they're looking to do
but again as I talk about in the book there's
there's 54 territories on the globe 172 buying
countries right so you have to realize that
some of those territories are gonna pay crap
they're gonna pay five seven ten grand but you
do have some that are gonna pay very well and you
you have to break that down when again when you
budget a film I always think with the end in mind
if I make this film and it's this genre and
this is the cast I'm realistically going to get
globally what is that actor or these few actors
do in a film of this nature or of this genre
and really break it down don't look at ask and
take sheets that every sales agent is going to
give you that tells you they're going to ask
for 150 grand in Germany and accept 75 grand
that's never going to happen that's those are
just numbers that they just provide these ask
and take sheets they're the same ones it doesn't
matter whose names on them they all look alike
don't go by that and sales agents will provide
that for you to get your business it's called
an ask take sheet and it's it's very
rare those numbers even come close
just find a walk and talk a walk and talk drama I
don't even know if it's a real term I've heard it
used by sales agents and distributors talking
about films that you can look at something
like When Harry Met Sally could be considered
like a walk and talk romantic comedy it's it's
not an action film it's not set in outer space
or with green screens it's it's practical
I think like you've got males a great example of
a walk and talk it's it still has the romantic
comedy elements when we did mistrust with Jane
Seymour that was that was also walk and talk drama
okay that's the first time i'd ever heard the
term and I started hearing it more and more I
think I think terms come and go but that's that's
my understanding of what it is I'm probably wrong
I'm sure your viewers will tell me how wrong I
am but that's that's what I understand it to be
and are those the hardest to sell they can be
tough depending on the cast so if if you're not
selling action you're not selling suspense
something that's getting the heart going
and it's it's a drama I you really need to
push the cast because you're asking people to
you think about you think about the independent
films that have done well and who's cast in them
and what they are and whenever whenever we're
teeing up to do a drama and we don't really
do those much anymore but when you tee out for
them it's about cast it's really just about cast
that's important we do an action film it's more
about okay we've got an action film coming let's
think about some of these actors who are going
to do well globally in different territories
and why and action cells suspense thrillers those
things do well everybody they translate into
every language and something else to keep in mind
sorry all no no go ahead they translate and they
translate in different languages but something
also think about is when when you do drama
it's something I talk to people a lot about
especially now coming out of where we've been
for the last year and a half do we do we really
want to deal with too much drama anymore I don't
know and the question is is does the world
want what we consider drama do they want our
drama do they want our problems drama comes
with a lot of emotion it comes with a lot of
feelings it comes with a lot of baggage it doesn't
know it doesn't mean it's bad it's it's what makes
some of the great dramas but I always I always
try to to remind people think about what we're
coming out of people have been living in their
their homes or their their dwellings for a urine
change and they haven't been able to socialize
much they haven't gone on vacation take them
places they want to go let them experience
exciting things that never gets old people want
to see beautiful things and and get excited and I
think you can incorporate that in drama but don't
forget always think about where the world is right
now and what if if you were totally detached from
this film completely detach yourself from it think
about the year you've just had do you want to sit
and watch somebody else go through some drama
right now totally for the drama genre I love it
but I just think you have to be sensitive to the
global climate when you're making certain product
but the queen's gambit worked that was gonna work
that was just awesome would you say that was some
action or no not not really but it had sensuality
it had it had some eroticism to it it had
mystique it had edgier seat moments because of
some of the the things that she went through
with her addictions and dealing with her
family drama and and her background I think
if I remember correctly I saw it not a long time
ago now but I think she was a was she adopted or
she was in an orphanage orphanage yeah
yeah there's there's a lot of baggage there
but they were able to educate an audience and
what I thought the coolest thing was and nobody
was surprised is when they talked about the
number of chess chess games that sold after
the success of that film and they couldn't
keep chess in stock this became the hottest
thing in the world everybody's buying chess and
I always so obviously they did something besides
being just such a brilliant execution of such a
great show is it got people excited about a new
hobby and and that's a cool thing too and we
could root for the underdog even though she was
kind of three steps ahead of most of the people
oh she was but she was yeah but in watching the
chess games and and the looks on the little the
little tells and the micro expressions and things
and and wondering was this going to be the
one that was going to take her down yeah
that's right and all of the you see pop and
circumstance that was around certain the the
notorious players and then sure this she's
going to come in so it was great I liked
I liked the janitor that taught her how to play
benny he needs a spin-off he sure does yeah yeah
yeah I wasn't sure where we were going with
him at first I wasn't either I was like ah
it's a little creepy and then I realized oh okay
okay he's a good guy I know exactly but yeah it
had that intrigue but no I think there's nothing
wrong with drama but I think during the drama you
have to have those those moments to breathe and
and experience new things as a filmmaker we've
talked about it before filmmaker's job is to bring
an audience to some place they've never been never
knew existed is always afraid to have gone to or
always wanted to go and I think in drama you can
still do that even with some of the experiences
or adventure that maybe a romance let's say it's
a a romantic it's not a comedy but it's a romantic
drama there's drama and maybe somebody's a widow
or somebody is cheating on a spouse and they're
going through this journey of a new relationship
and that's that's when things almond king did
very well if you watch like nine and a half
weeks what made that in its time was was what
that relationship did between the incredible
sex scenes the thrill and the exuberation of
that relationship and where it took its viewers
and it's time and I think that's important to
do sure and there was romance in the queen's
gambit there was that's right that's right
yes but there was also excitement and the way
and then I’ll just close it there but just the a
lot of the shots were I'm not sure what the exact
terminology is but they're like these up shots of
of them following her upstairs and getting like
this wide view of her sort of walking into
a room but but also in your right and what
was really cool about it is they took us places
we've never been and her journey when she became
a professional chess player the places around the
world she went and some of these incredible rooms
and these halls and these hotels and we got to
experience that especially during 2020 when we
were all stuck at home is when most of us saw that
and even Shit's Creek you talk about a show that
exploded during 2020 everybody was talking about
that show early on in the 2020 and and here was
just this great concept of this this very wealthy
family that had everything stripped from them that
had to go to this small town but what what fun
and that's circumstantial comedy that I think
translates a lot better than slapstick comedy
because people can get that from all walks of life
every language that'll translate so I think you
just have to be smart and picking your content
just you have to again we talk about how us
artists are so myopic and selfish you just have
to step back and say okay if you were detached
from this realistically how do you think this
would be accepted take your passion take your
investment of your time or your your talent
away from this for just five minutes really think
about how this would do on a global scale and why
how much money can filmmakers expect to make from
streaming services today don't expect anything I
think every deal is different every situation is
different there are there are some really cool
streaming services or platforms that are
popping up all the time that Tubi’s a new one
obviously you've got your Netflix your Amazon
your Hulu I think I think Netflix if you make
a deal with them they acquire the project I
think people will be surprised for what they
actually acquire independent films for and
people need to realize they pay that over I
think two years it's not just one big check
and that's fine that's that's what they do
there are some some AOD platforms that are that
are doing surprisingly well I never say what
anybody should expect I work with sales agents and
distributors all the time that are working with
films that have been dead catalog collect dust in
a closet haven't seen a light a day in 15-20 years
they're throwing them on some of these AOD
platforms and they're bringing in 5 to 20 grand
a month just on like dead titles it and then
you have stuff that costs a lot more that are
recent and slick and they're not making a dime
there's I don't think there's there's really a
guarantee for anything I think that there are some
really good streaming platforms out there some
obviously the the more the merrier if you can
get different territories different platforms
they have some platforms now that'll get your
your work out on you can make deals with some
distributors they'll get your get your work out
on 32 different platforms every major cable outlet
including Xbox and playstation those are some
really attractive things but how well do they pay
I don't want to give you a number and say
this is what you can expect because it
what we always have to remember about this
business is to hope for the best prepare
for the worst and expect the unexpected and it
goes back to learning something new every day
there are some streaming platforms that I've heard
are just oh my god you got to get with them and
you see what the deal is and you just say that's
the last thing I want to do and then there are
some platforms that you've never heard of that
you just say I wouldn't be caught dead being
affiliated with this and then they say well sit
down here's what our mg is we're going to give you
a minimum guarantee for one year and then after
the second year you have first right of refusal if
you're happy with that we're going to pay you 40
afterward you sit there and you go so wait you're
going to give an mg on a streaming deal for that
much money huh okay and these things I get hit
with these things every other day where there's
the misconception of some of the bigger ones
and then there's this I've never heard of
you before but you're willing to guarantee it
I wish I had the answer for you but
I think it's one of those things that
every film every film with a cast from every
filmmaker is going to be treated differently
in that I just do I just do I don't think
there is a tried and true number yet
there's too many new platforms
popping up they're everywhere.